[Music]
and limp-dick Revenge news Wow wet
noodle submitted by love from Sweden see
you then I love Sweden I've been there
75 year old man bent on revenge killed
the surgeon who left him with erectile
dysfunction oh wow
75 like he was about to die anyway I
guess he had to get that last verb a
blow up another 20 years that's only
that's true that's a long time like you
have rest in peace he died at 91 91 I
can't believe he didn't die by any
disease about at all
I can't I feel like a s team like a PD
or something or whatever what is that I
said maybe they hit him he was rich
enough to keep him alive until then yeah
he probably literally had all of his
blood transfusion out of his body at
some point he looked good though 491 is
anyone right yeah yeah you looked how do
you go click [ __ ] 491 huh
you know didn't you gotta look like
you're 130 okay gotcha hahaha cuz at
that there's a point where it's like we
don't have photographs of anyone who
lives longer
you don't man like 90 ones pretty up
there man yeah he doesn't look like he's
falling apart or he didn't look like he
was falling apart you know I had his
hair look good and you know his face was
you know you know like some old people
look like they're melting dude [ __ ]
Tommy Lee Jones lately it's nuts now it
got insane dating he's dating one I
didn't think about Tommy wait Tommy Lee
Jones the actor right oh no he's you
know he's dating a former minor diviner
oh he is Ellen
Brittany Furlan oh really oh yeah I
recently heard that and I was like what
anyway about this story so this man back
in 2013
he drove 55 miles from Lake Elsinore all
the way to Newport Beach to go kill this
doctor and so what happened was this
happened in California mm-hmm yeah so
this man he had an alias well he booked
an appointment under an alias Allen gold
but his real name is Stanwood Elka okay
why would you book a doctor's a plan
he didn't wanna get made formal coz he
has to kill him right no or yeah you did
that when he went to go kill him oh the
first time you encountered this doctor
was back in 1992 and back then this
doctor crutch yeah so back then this
doctor was a resident at a VA hospital
in Long Beach and so that's when his
name against mr. snuffleupagus sound
like a cartoon character Stanwood Elka
Stanwood went in and he was complaining
about his frequent urination so then
that's when this dr. Ronald Gilbert's
he told him we were wait how old is the
other time 75 75 when he killed him Oh
in 92 he was no no no it so I don't you
old are you asking and when you when
when he went to see the doctor and then
with a p-problem yeah
192 okay that helps yeah right now you
got it ask you when did he first see
this doctor in 90210 because you asked
about an age or something how old he was
I don't know anyways moving out but it
was in 92 I get his 50s or something I
can't do them and he lost his dick in
his fifties dude know what a pimp
robbing this so then uh that's when
what's his name again
rock you forget that what altus ok sorry
ok Alan goes well kiss and Gilbert dream
original okay
how do I thank you for getting it name
Stanwood what okay so
Stanwood when he went in that's when dr.
Gilbert recommended a surgery because he
diagnosed him with a urethral stricture
which is the narrowing of the urethra
and then the doctor recommended a
surgery and then I didn't his urethra
yeah so why didn't big urethra what does
that mean like how does that make you
pee more I don't know it'll take so long
I know and then you got to make the two
bigger so the P can come out P this is a
bigger urethra yeah already sounds like
a logic can't get all the pee out so he
keeps peeing like every [ __ ] hour
that make sense can't empty his bladder
maybe that was my roommate dude he went
every 15 minutes I swear they need to
make the funnel a bigger tunnel yes I
mean after that surgery after he got
that surgery he was left with
incontinence and consonants which is
where he pees a lot Intercontinental
breakfast leaving that it's with its
lack of voluntary control over your
knees so he pees himself yeah he was
left with that was peeing like yeah with
penis he probably laughs and little
squirts out like poor guy with a low sex
drive and also with erectile dysfunction
after that botched surgery god that's
[ __ ] up also before it was fine he's
like I don't wanna [ __ ] I peed myself
thank you would he would have frequent
urination nothing like once every 10
minutes before and then now he can't do
anything now he's like involuntary
involuntarily so I got so loose and he
has a low sex drive and he had erectile
decide what did he do
[ __ ] him pull out his balls and neuter
him so to be clear here the this doctor
dr. Gilbert he was not the one that
performed the surgery he just
recommended it and he diagnosed him but
then later on down the line
he found out from different doctors that
he had been misdiagnosed and that the
procedure was unless
I went to another place to get the work
done so it's kind of like one doctor
said you probably should get this done
but I don't do it here and he went to
what where the [ __ ] you know so I don't
think he's so he was he was just he was
just interning yes good answer but you
know you just he's just a student back
then right mm-hmm
something like that I mean he's still
technically a doctor of your resident
but you're still a student throwing a
residency yeah so you got to do what
four years or something
depends on the specialty at so then uh
because of that botched surgery leaving
him the way he left him he lost his
longtime girlfriend that he had hoped to
marry because she needed dick absolutely
it felt like Debbie was someone that
pees on myself all day long not to yeah
and the town of the problems he would
make house think about he has to wear a
diaper to be honest yeah yeah man it's
like for the rest of the next 50 20
years he kept having this grudge fixated
on Gilbert
dr. Gilbert cuz he was doing that
diagnosed um and so finally he ended up
purchasing a handgun in December 2012 so
then he mapped out directions to
Gilbert's current office at that time
that's crazy that that's his only
solution like not find another doctor to
fix them but to buy a handgun twenty
years twenty yard he tried and they
couldn't fix him could they could not be
you gonna get any help first um they
don't mention that they don't mention
anything did they did he learn about
this later
like like later do you even need to get
that surgery I don't know how much
longer your [ __ ]
or was it like two years later he found
out it just says later oh it probably
doesn't matter I mean he's stuck with
the shitty penis for that many years
like whether he needed surgery or not
I'd still be pretty pissed
yeah then like he's super toasty yeah
yeah it was also reported that
everything bad that was happening in his
life since that surgery he would blame
it on that surgery and he would just
have his grudge against that doctor and
so um he went over to his office shot
him ten times
oh yeah and he told the he told the the
receptionist like hey I'm insane call
the cops I'm crazy so we did that I
assumed after he shut the gate yeah yeah
crazy people don't know they're crazy
yeah but they're saying that because he
tried to plead insanity
he said he was insane not to move he
should move to make yeah he should have
gone up to the lady and he's like I need
some cotton candy cuz I'm a cocky boy
yeah but not like hello I am a crazy
person please call the police
thank you very much I'll take it a
lollipop
thank you you know yeah and so after the
trial lasted three three weeks after
only 40 minutes of deliberation that's
when the jury gave him a guilty verdict
I was really hoping it he's gonna be
spending the rest of his life in prison
his peeing around cells it's not long
yeah and that doctor that he killed the
day before he got killed he was granted
or like he received a 30 million dollar
offer from a corporate buyer because he
was he started a pharmaceutical company
that was focusing on treatments on
sexual dysfunction and so like right
before that is when he got that offer in
this well maybe you could fix them I
know you left behind kids and a wife and
that what if this what if what if this
cat did something [ __ ] up with the
doctor and doctors I'm gonna [ __ ] with
your all your [ __ ] dude your dick is
never gonna work again you know I'm
saying because this can't did some [ __ ]
to the to the doctor that we didn't know
about or a family member of the doctor
here's the guy can never remember the
Stanwood if you're going for insanity
you got to like make the cross you know
the first got booked I'm assuming
because the hair color is different than
now
now he's on a wheelchair on he's [ __ ]
up too because they're saying that now
he's in a wheelchair and he's like going
deaf so he has a hearing aid and when
the doctor's family went up to do like
their testimony this will took out his
hearing aid we didn't have to listen
yeah okay so he was just like a young
fresh out of medical school student and
you know maybe he made a mistake and
misdiagnosed yeah and he was killed like
he was the one to only make a
recommendation to right like that was
the other doctor that actually performed
the surgery yeah I think it would make a
little more sense if it was him pushing
the surgery agenda on him because you
know like there's I guess you could make
more money that way if you keep telling
your patients you have problems and he
was a shady doctor that kept telling
there's you know patients that you need
to get this done and that done so they
could make more money
there's no rationalizing this though I
to me if that happened to my dick I'll
kill a man even think about it which guy
though the guy that recommended or the
guy that performed the surgery and all
of them and their and their families you
know just in case I missed a spot you
know I'm saying like you you you so my
wife leaves me or the girlfriend or
whatever I pissed myself all the time
came and see and move without pissing
and [ __ ] myself or whatever right
yeah and then like you know you can't
have a date ever you can get a depends
brand deal well that's just looking on
the bright side too much I don't think
this guy had a shot you know you smell
it like Dookie everyday yeah you can't
even jerk it in his own home and
experience a moment of happiness before
he feels really say it again you know
I'm saying don't be have drugs though or
like he gave me good implant and he
could like manually pump up his dick
that sounds great doesn't it am I
talking about talking about you know you
can get an implant where you have to
hook up a [ __ ] hose into it and then
it pumps your dick you just leave all
the lady waits for you
you just got to keep her in the living
room with the martini
hold on loud music switch I had to do
this for the switch turn on crazy-ass
EDM music so she can hear the pop right
deflates midway through is it so [ __ ]
dark in here and he's like wait I see a
little bit of light it takes off his
[ __ ] shoe he throws it at the light
so she can't see the pump he's putting
in his own dick see I'm saying yeah you
buy a gun you go to the store you buy a
gun you plot it you find the man you
kill them you shoot them ate as many
times as the gun has indeed that clip
that's right and then you draw and then
you throw the gun at them I'm not saying
it was right I'm saying I can understand
that like from a certain point of view I
wonder if he feels any better now I know
I want to I want to know because you
know in the movies they always go you
know the revenge doesn't doesn't solve
anything I don't feel any different
but I feel like they're told to say that
like movies aren't supposed to say if
felt great or the cops are never
supposed to lose even sweet Julia if a
doctor closed up your vagina so you
could never [ __ ] you know your real
boyfriend I guess he's real you're
telling me you wouldn't do some [ __ ]
yeah I don't know that's really I mean
of course they're basically the cancer
of the other day I mean I would be upset
I would obviously be upset bottom I feel
like at that point I would want to get a
second consultation to be sure if that's
what I needed that well it's like no no
your vagina's close it's like in a
sliding glass doors like yeah I mean I
would probably have the same mindset as
that's the medical procedure see ya even
sweet Julia sweetest person there is is
buying a gun at a hardware store yeah
cuz they any file is off the numbers you
know I mean at the same time would be
like oh as much as I would want to kill
him I don't think I can actually bring
myself to do it I don't think women care
that much about being able to have sex
in there because it was put in the
budget yeah we have other holes yeah we
are here
we got here we got here we got here
you're cool yeah hello guys I hope you
guys enjoy the video please remember to
give us a big thumbs up and a like like
like and also when you guys sign on
YouTube make sure just kidding news is
the first thing you watch every single
day because we post videos every day ok
for more videos